so viel schauen in den plenarsaal rein
denn es geht weiter mit der nächsten
debatte
da geht es um hilfe für unternehmen ein
sofortprogramm für unternehmen und
beschäftigten ausspricht julia klöckner
sieht die hinter der internationale
währungsfonds die bundesregierung sie
korrigieren in diesen wochen laufend
ihre wachstumsprognosen nach unten und
die inflationserwartungen nach oben und
unsere wirtschaft kommt ab dem zweiten
quartal in sehr unsicheres fahrer nur
noch zwei prozent wachstum für 22 und
inflationsrate über sechs prozent das
ist eine massive preissteigerung der
höchste wert seit 40 jahren erst corona
und jetzt der russland ukraine krieg
unsere volkswirtschaft die bleibt im
krisenmodus die belastungen für
unternehmen und beschäftigte die nehmen
kein ende es geht um belastungen die auf
dauer nicht zu verkraften sind und es
geht um das potenzial für eine echte
wirtschaftskrise und von monat zu monat
werden die wirtschaftszahlen schlechter
da sind abstrakte zahlen verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen aber das sind
ganz konkrete belastungen für betriebe
und beschäftigte vor ort
schauen wir uns die hohen energiekosten
haben die papier- oder glas industrie
hat ihre produktion teilweise schon
stillgelegt das dicke ende kommt noch
wenn über langfristige lieferverträge
sind viele unternehmen momentan noch
gegen hohe energiekosten abgesichert
schauen wir uns die lieferketten an in
der automobilindustrie laufen die bänder
teilweise oder nur eingeschränkt
wichtige zulieferer teile zulieferer
teile wie kabelbäume die fehlen uns wir
wissen vor shanghai über 300 transporter
stehen dort fest es gibt engpässe es
gibt frachtschiffe die nicht entladen
werden können und unser leben das wird
teurer und das spüren alle ob an der
zapfsäule bei strom und heizungen oder
beim einkauf im supermarkt auch die
preise für getreide sind übrigens
deutlich gestiegen und ich will das hier
kurz sagen die bundesregierung
gibt keine antwort auf die sich
abzeichnende wirtschaftskrise was die
bundesregierung macht ist unterlassungs
spiel an dieser stelle auch etwas sagen
zum
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister dass in
dieser zeit wohl lagerhallen für
nahrungsmittel zerstört werden wo anthem
nicht gesichert werden können dass diese
bundesregierung jetzt darauf verzichtet
ökologische vorrangflächen für die
nahrungsmittelproduktion zu nutzen das
ist schrecklich dass ist vorsatz und das
ist kein handeln aus einem bus um dieser
krise auch entgegen zu gehen was macht
die ampel sie tut so als ginge sie das
alles gar nicht ansieht beschließt
übrigens fortlaufend auch
mehrbelastungen vor allen dingen tot sie
sich aus bei den berichts und
dokumentationspflichten und gerade die
kleineren und mittleren unternehmen die
brauchen mehr luft zum atmen und beim
facharbeitermangel sehen wir das ist
eine wachstumsbremse und genau hier an
dieser stelle wäre die bundesregierung
gefragt eben nicht im stückwerk zu
handeln sondern mit einem guss wir
brauchen jetzt einen impuls für unsere
wirtschaft denn diese krisen müssen
entschieden angepackt werden eine
entschlossene ausrichtung der
wirtschaftspolitik auf
leistungsfähigkeit auf digitalisierung
auf nachhaltigkeit das ist gefragt und
weil die bundesregierung das nicht tut
haben wir diesen antrag heute vorgelegt
ein gesamtkonzept aus einem guss
sofortprogramm für unternehmen und
beschäftigte das fordern wir von der
bundesregierung sie machen ist nicht wir
legen es ihnen vor und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
dürfen die unternehmen die beschäftigte
jetzt eben gerade nicht im regen stehen
lassen wir brauchen ein neues bürokratie
entlastungsgesetz das melde- und
aufbewahrungsfristen verkürzt und
gegebenenfalls auch durch eine
genehmigungsfähige ersetzt und wir
schlagen die einführung von gründer
schutzzonen vor gründer sollen die
ersten zwei jahre weitgehend von
bürokratischen vorschriften befreit
werden und für die krisenzeit da
brauchen wir ein belastungsmoratorium
und das ist vielleicht für den einen
oder anderen so locker daher gesagt nur
schauen wir uns die eu ebene an sie
macht gerade so weiter übrigens
unterstützt durch die bundesregierung
als gäbe ist diesen krieg und diese
kriege krisen nicht es geht jetzt darum
auch zu überlegen ob die taxonomie
vorstellung von
dokumentationspflichten wirklich das
sind was wir jetzt in dieser krisenzeit
brauchen und deshalb brauchen wir jetzt
ein belastungsmoratorium eine bürokratie
bremse und müssen einen turbo anschalten
im übrigen für abschreibung ist es ja
schön dass die bundesregierung das in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag stehen hat aber
worauf warten sie dennoch wenn nicht
jetzt wann dann brauchen wir diese turbo
abschreibung um einen schub für unsere
wirtschaft hier in deutschland zu
bekommen
und genauso sieht es bei der kalten
progression aus worauf warten sie reform
des arbeitszeitgesetzes nicht tägliche
höchstarbeitszeit sondern wöchentliche
höchstarbeitszeit auch in der digitalen
arbeitswelt das fachblatts der
einwanderungsgesetze mir gemacht bringen
sich doch jetzt zum blühen wo sind zb
auf ihre umsetzung offensive bei der
digitalisierung bus der zuständige
minister und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen allein das zeichen dass sie als
koalition nicht bereit sind über das
handelsabkommen sitter abzustimmen
morgen dass sie es erneut zum zweiten
mal nicht auf die tagesordnung setzen
lassen mit ihrer mehrheit zeigt dass sie
die zeichen der zeit nicht erkannt haben
wir müssen jetzt handeln jetzt braucht
die wirtschaft einen schub wir haben es
bei der finanz und wirtschaftskrise
gesehen dass es funktionieren kann mit
den richtigen rahmenbedingungen was
machen sie sie haben keinen aktionsplan
sie haben konsistente strategie und mir
sagen wie wir brauchen für made in
germany einen gesamten sap ist dieses
sofortprogramm
deshalb sagen wir auch mehr geld für
verteidigung und unsere freiheit setzt
aber eine funktionierende und blühende
wirtschaft voraus und dafür fordern wir
diese zustimmung zu unserem antrag die
wirtschaftspolitische sprecherin der
unionsfraktion julia klöckner war das
hat hier die debatte eröffnet es geht um
hilfen für unternehmen und beschäftigte
die
unionsfraktion hat dazu einen antrag
vorgelegt will ein umfassendes
entlastungspaket für die wirtschaft
hören wir mal was die spd sagt dann
westfalen wie bei kollegen und kollegen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die situation in der wir uns zurzeit
befinden ist sehr ernst die themen
nehmen mit jeder sitzungswoche an größe
zu und wir brauchen eine kluge
abgewogene intelligente politik die auf
diese situation reagieren und das was
die bundesregierung zurzeit leistet das
sehen wir in den entlastungsprogramm die
nicht einem antrag der opposition
bedürfen sondern die lange schon auf dem
weg sind das was die bürgerinnen und
bürgern energiepreisen zurzeit zu
stemmen haben und das was die wirtschaft
an belastungen aushalten hat wird mit
den maßnahmen die die bundesregierung
und die ampel koalition auf den weg
gebracht hat begegnet und das nennen wir
soziale marktwirtschaft man diese
wehrten damit her
respekt und anerkennung für das was die
bundesregierung in gänze aber vor allen
dingen auch unser wirtschaftsminister
leistet er hat eine menge zu tun unsere
energie versorgungssicherheit zu
organisieren und gleichzeitig den
transformationsprozess in dem unserer
wirtschaftlich befindet zu begleiten und
das ist genau das was wir machen das ist
die sozial ökologische marktwirtschaft
die jetzt genau diese dynamik erfährt
die in den vorgänger regierung nicht zu
sehen war meine damen und herren wir
haben mit dem oster paket was jetzt
vorliegt klar aufgezeichnet wie die
ambitionierten ausbauziele für
erneuerbare energien gestaltet werden
müssen und genau das ist die basis für
industrielle produktion für
wertschöpfung in deutschland und da geht
es dabei natürlich aus kohle und öl und
gas zu reduzieren gerade jetzt mit der
dynamik die versierte seit dem 24
februar haben zu organisieren aber
gleichzeitig auch zu gucken wie kriegen
wir die erneuerbare welt organisiert und
da ist neben dem ausbau natürlich auch
die frage infrastruktur nicht nur lade
infrastruktur sondern auch pipeline
stromnetze hybride netzplanung und genau
das was an speichermöglichkeiten
notwendig ist für einen hochlauf der
wasserstoffwirtschaft genau das sind die
dinge die jetzt zu organisieren sind
dafür brauchen wir auch in einem
europäischen kontext regelungen in die
wir eingebettet sein müssen und deshalb
bedarf es auch nicht nur nationaler
programme sondern auch noch einmal den
dialog mit der europäischen kommission
und mit dem europäischen parlament ob
die dinge die bisher vereinbart worden
sind passen zu dem was jetzt an der
tagesordnung ist und lassen sie mich
noch sagen frau klöckner
der antrag der cdu csu ja es sind einige
wichtige punkte da drin wir haben den
antrag sicherlich als
diskussionsgrundlage im ausschuss da
können wir die debatte noch einmal
vertiefen aber ich muss sagen das was
sie hier aufgeschrieben haben braucht
auch ein finanzierungskonzept und da
sind sie da kommt überhaupt nicht von
deshalb
und deshalb ist das schon seriöser mit
den hilfsprogrammen die jetzt auf den
weg gebracht worden sind entlastung der
haushalte ein klarer fokussierung auf
eine soziale balance in diesem land wir
lassen die menschen nicht allein mit dem
was dort passiert und ein klarer fokus
darauf auch den standort deutschland so
zu organisieren dass es eben mit den
neuen technologien vorwärts geht wenn
man heute mit unternehmerinnen und
unternehmen im dialog ist merkt man doch
die aufbruchstimmung die zuversicht dass
da was passieren muss und ich war
gestern abend bei einer veranstaltung
hier in berlin wo man zeigt an dem
beispiel wilhelmshaven wo sich der
bürgermeister mit dem land niedersachsen
mit bund mit den akteuren und akteuren
vor ort aus der wirtschaft zusammen tut
wo die unternehmen investieren dort den
offshore anbindung erneuerbaren strom
mit wasserstoffwirtschaft zu
organisieren und neben wilhelmshaven
wird das auch brunsbüttel wird das stade
wird das rostock seit genau diese
impulse setzen wir jetzt und das ist die
dynamik die diese ampel koalition nach
vorne bringen und dafür werden wir auch
im wirtschaftsausschuss noch diskutieren
müssen ja
wir haben durchaus grund für zuversicht
bislang mangelt nicht an geld glaube
schon dass die unternehmen genug kapital
haben diese investition zu wuppen mit
staatlicher unterstützung wir werden
noch mal überlegen ob wir dieses geld
was wir jetzt in der kompensation von
hohen energiepreisen nicht auch
bereitstellen müssen für abschreibungen
von jetzt investitionen die getätigt
werden um noch schneller eine
unabhängigkeit von fossilen energien zu
bekommen auch das wird thema sein für
die nächsten wochen und monaten wie
gesagt die
rahmenbedingungen verändern sich sehr
dynamisch und sehr schnell wir
vermitteln zuversicht und organisieren
sicherheit in diesem wandel für diesen
prozess und ich darf sie auffordern die
unter die regierung in dieser frage zu
unterstützen herzlichen dank an
sagt bernd westphal der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der spd
fraktion und hat doch noch mal darauf
aufmerksam gemacht dass auch die
bundesregierung vor drei wochen bereits
ein milliardenschweres hilfspaket für
unternehmen in deutschland beschlossen
hat die von den folgen der ukraine
kriegs des ukraine kriegs betroffen sind
enrico kommenden jetzt für die fdp
frau präsidentin meine lieben damen und
herren kollegen
dieser antrag der union ist ein reiner
schaufensterantrag
liebe union liebe frau klöckner sie
waren ja
regierungsmitglied in der letzten in der
letzten legislatur was hat sie
eigentlich in den 16 jahren der
regierungszeit daran gehindert all das
was sie jetzt hier in diesen antrag
schreiben damals auch durchzusetzen
weder der krieg noch ihre pandemie sind
für den derzeitigen schlamassel
verantwortlich sondern ihre eigene
politik sie reden jetzt von
bürokratieabbau dabei sind sie es doch
die diesen mount everest bürokratischer
vorschriften aufgetürmt haben sie sind
doch dafür verantwortlich dass der
mittelstand in auflagen und
berichtspflichten versinkt und gegenüber
konzern um ein vielfaches belastet wird
und sie haben doch die rein ideologisch
getriebenen verschärfungen der anti
diskriminierungs und gleichstellungs
gesetzgebung und die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes zu verantworten
sie haben doch erst die
energieintensiven betriebe durch ihre
monster steuern ins ausland getrieben
und jetzt fordern sie eine verlängerung
des spitzenausgleich übrigens gerade für
kmu ein bürokratisches monster haben sie
sich mal den paragraf 10 des
stromsteuergesetzes
angesehen dass es so ein teil wenn sie
liebe kollegen von der union ernsthaft
am bürokratieabbau interessiert wären
reicht eine einzige forderung
nämlich die rückabwicklung von 16 jahren
cdu csu und merkel politik
meiner und herren kollegen einiges in
ihrem antrag ist ja gut gemeint vieles
ist aber reines blendwerk
sie wollen jetzt eine entfristung der
home office pauschale wissend dass diese
durch die anrechnung der
werbungskostenpauschale gerade bei
normalen arbeitnehmern einfach verpufft
sie von der cdu waren es aber die
unseren antrag im übrigen schon vor
corona mit tatsächlichen und
substanziellen erleichterungen für
mobile arbeit abgelehnt haben sie von
der cdu csu sind es die für den massiven
wohlstandsverlust des mittelstands in
deutschland durch die kalte progression
verantwortlich sind nicht nur dass sie
in den vergangenen jahren dagegen nichts
unternommen haben sie haben die existenz
der kalten progression sogar schlicht
geleugnet und sie sind doch mit ihrer
obskuren energiepolitik dafür
verantwortlich dass kaum ein normaler
arbeitnehmer die schweige denn ein
rentner noch seine strom- oder
heizkostenrechnung bezahlen kann
aber das beste das beste ist du wirklich
dass sie von der union jetzt ernsthaft
die verlängerung der laufzeiten von
kernkraftwerken
verlangen sie haben doch erst die kohle
und kernkraft beerdigt und damit die
energie krise und die abhängigkeiten
verursacht und meine damen und herren
wir
jetzt tipp wieder aus der mottenkiste
rauszuholen nach diesem
globalisierungs und lieferketten
desaster der letzten jahre darauf muss
man erst mal kommen da dieser antrag
keine der von ihnen zu verantwortenden
ursachen für die krise benennt und
behebt ist der anspruch mit diesem
antrag die bestehenden probleme lösen zu
wollen
illusorisch das reicht schlicht nicht
aus deshalb werden wir uns zu diesem
antrag enthalten den öko sozialistischen
unserem antrag der linken leben lang
gesehen
[Applaus]
enrico kommt irgendwann das für die afg
fraktionen dass die nicht die ohne
geschlossen werden sollte noch jemand
hier seien der oder die noch nicht
abstimmen konnte dann wäre es jetzt noch
möglich und ich gebe das wort für
bündnis 90 die grünen den kollegen
dieter janitschek und die abstimmung im
hintergrund läuft ja noch zu dem
vorherigen tagesordnungspunkte wo es um
den antrag ging zur unterstützung der
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
unter anderem dieter janitschek jetzt
hier in der aussprache wo es um hilfen
um so frau ein sofortprogramm für
unternehmen beschäftigte geht der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
grünen
die lage der deutschen wirtschaft ist
vergleichsweise
robust angesichts der krisen die wir
gerade global zu erleiden haben der
schreckliche angriffskrieg russlands in
der ukraine
die störung der lieferketten jetzt
aktuell auch wieder in shanghai und
peking übrigens demnächst auch in china
aber natürlich eben auch die folgen der
korona pandemie darüber hinaus die wir
alle noch zu bewältigen haben dafür
stehen wir verhältnismäßig gut da das
ist aber keine garantie für die zukunft
ich hatte heute früh auch ein gespräch
mit unternehmen der logistikbranche die
sehr stark betroffen sind von den
preisschocks auf den energiemärkten lng
zum beispiel hat sich im verhältnis zu
diesem jahr noch einmal deutlich
verteuert das heißt auf der einen seite
müssen wir jetzt krisenbewältigung
machen für das was wir über jahrzehnte
dafür steht er sparen ihre regierungen
der vergangenen jahrzehnte insbesondere
nämlich das nichthandeln bei
erneuerbaren energien energieeffizienz
modernisierung digitalisierung das
müssen wir jetzt in aller schärfe
anschieben und nach vorne kommen jetzt
unsere vor ort und auf der anderen seite
auf der anderen seite müssen wir
zielgerichtet helfen und das ist der
unterschied von uns zu ihnen sie haben
einen antrag geschrieben wo sie eine
einigkeit haben mit den kollegen von den
linken das ist die maßlosigkeit in der
ausgabenpolitik
wir sind bei der frage der entlastungen
nicht zielgenau
wir wollen unseren haushalt nicht
überlasten wir wollen die nötigen
anpassungen der wirtschaft weg von
russischen öl und gas
befördern wir wollen nicht anreize
schaffen damit wir noch mehr verbrauchen
das sind unterschiede die wir
und wir müssen gleichzeitig uns mit
unseren europäischen partnern absprechen
dass du mir bei den hilfsprogrammen
deswegen gibt es das dass temporary
crisis framework das orientiert sich bei
den energieintensiven unternehmen an den
notwendigkeiten die wir haben und es
wird uns trotzdem nicht gelingen all den
wohlstandsverlust märz hat das ja in
einem bemerkenswerten beitrag
ausgesprochen wir sind möglicherweise in
einer überschreitung unserer wohlstand
stelle angekommen die frage ist nur wie
verteilen wir sozusagen dann auch die
verluste muss mal andersrum zu sagen das
heißt ja nicht dass alle gleich
profitieren oder entsprechen nicht
profitieren und deswegen kommt jetzt
darauf an wirtschaftliche hilfen dort wo
sie notwendig sind auf der einen seite
zeitlich begrenzt zielgerichtet nicht
für alle ich muss nicht den grundpreis
für benzin für suv fahrer garantieren
aber ich muss dafür sorgen dass zum
beispiel menschen die mit gas heizen
durch den winter kommen ich muss dafür
sorgen dass ich überhaupt noch gas aber
durch den winter zu kommen ich muss
dafür sorgen als staatliche institution
dass wir modernisierungsinvestitionen
jetzt anschieben darauf kommt es an dass
es unser ansatz von wirtschaftshilfen
und ihr antrag vor klöckner hat die ein
oder andere
analyse und stellschraube die ich auch
unterschreiben würde beim thema
bürokratieabbau bei der frage der
planungs beschleunigung da wollen wir
vorangehen aber was nicht jeden dann
möchte ich abschließend ist dass sie
wirtschaftliche kompetenz dadurch
abbilden indem sie maßlos sind in ihren
forderungen
und alles das fordern was in
lobbyverbände einfluss dann aufgabe
einer regierung ist es zu handeln aber
zu handeln für die die es brauchen und
das tun wir und das tun wir kraftvoll
vielen dank
zwei anträge liegen dieser debatte
zugrunde einer der unionsfraktion und
einer der linksfraktion dieter janecek
hier von den grünen der sie den beiden
anträgen eine gewisse maßlosigkeit in
der ausgabenpolitik über den
unionsantrag haben jetzt schon einiges
gehört jetzt werden wir beim nächsten
redner einiges zum linken-antrag hören
die linke forderte ebenfalls ein
hilfsprogramm für wirtschaft wohlstand
und beschäftigung
unter anderem fordert die linke
maßnahmen zur entlastung etwa ein
sondervermögen in höhe von 100
milliarden euro für energiesicherheit
und energie
souveränität
für die linke spricht alexander ulrich
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
janitschek das ist ja wirklich schon
sehr interessant dass ein grüner und
maßlosigkeit vorwirft weil wir 100
milliarden fordern für eine
klimaneutrale wirtschaft und lebensweise
in deutschland währenddessen die grünen
bei 100 milliarden für aufrüstung kein
vertreter haben also auch die grünen
müssen doch eigentlich sagen
investitionen in klima gerechtigkeit
während sinnvoller wie für aufrüstung
dass unser vorschlag die antwort auf den
krieg von putin kann doch nicht
aufrüstung bedeutend sondern muss auch
energie souveränität sicherheit und
ausbau dieser energien bedeuten dass wir
da war die grünen darum kämpfen einen
ähnlichen weg zu gehen dass sich die
grünen in einem halben jahr eine
regierungsvereinbarung so verändern
hätte ich nie gedacht
wir sind in einer wirtschaftlich
schwierigen lage der
bundeswirtschaftsminister musste gestern
die wachstumsprognosen korrigieren wir
glauben dass auch diese zahlen noch sehr
optimistisch sind die jetzt dargestellt
werden denn viele sachen sind doch nicht
eingepreist und deshalb sind auch die
hilfen die bisher von der
bundesregierung beschlossen worden sind
sowohl für die wirtschafts soforthilfen
als auch die programme
unambitioniert und viel zu klein und ob
sie sozialverbände und auch die
gewerkschaften sind oder viele anderen
interessengruppen ich sagen hier muss
nachgebessert werden und hervis fans
sagen dass das wäre soziale
marktwirtschaft erklären sie mal einen
rentner oder einer rentnerin warum sie
300 euro nicht bekommen das hat mit
sozialer marktwirtschaft nichts zu tun
eine große gruppe die sehr belastet
ihnen an den rand gestellt da müssen sie
im gesetzgebungsverfahren noch mal
nachbessern
wir haben deutlich gemacht dass wir
druck machen müssen bei dem umbau der
wirtschaft auf wasserstoff auf
erneuerbare energien dass wir da viel
mehr geld in die hand nehmen müssen und
dann kommt ja immer die fdp die sagt das
ist nicht zu machen wir müssen wir das
schnell zurück zur schuldenbremse und
zur schwarzen null wir hoffen dass auch
diese krise mal erkennt aber dass wir
durch diese krise erkennt dass die
schuldenbremse und die schwarze null
keine zukunft haben kann wir brauchen
dringend
zukunftsinvestitionen damit deutschland
nicht abgehängt wird und dieser krieg
und die wunder pandemie haben gezeigt
wir müssen deutlich mehr investieren
nicht nur in deutschland sondern auch
europa deshalb muss auch der stabilitäts
und wachstumspakt in europa reformiert
werden die goldene regel dass
investitionen nicht mitgerechnet werden
bei der verschuldung muss endlich
eingeführt werden
[Applaus]
aber und das ist bei einer sozialen
marktwirtschaft ist da müsste das auch
eine antwort sein das wird auch mal die
frage stellen jetzt zahlt sind
eigentlich auch die kosten die der staat
aufwenden muss und wer hört nichts davon
und dieser bundesregierung das auch mal
die krisen und kriegsgewinnler mal
beteiligt werden an diesen kosten es
gibt sehr viele unternehmen die sich die
hände reiben auch nach dem heutigen
beschluss schwere waffen zu liefern
warum wir noch mal hin besteuert mal
diesen krisen im kriegsgewinnler damit
endlich auch mal die mit dazu beitragen
dass der staat seine aufgaben erfüllen
kann deshalb ran an die vermögensabgaben
an rand an die extraprofite der
wirtschaft
und wir haben die debatte ja schon sehr
aufgeführt in der janacek ich verstehe
nicht wir haben gemeinsam noch zu
oppositionszeiten
auch das programm der gewerkschaften mit
dem industrieverbänden verteidigt wir
waren viel mehr zukunftsinvestition das
ist die sachen die zahlen genannt worden
von mindestens 500 milliarden den
nächsten zehn jahren warum stellen sie
jetzt sind uns sagen das wäre maßlos als
vor einem halben jahr die richtige
entscheidung war sie können nicht nur
weil sie jetzt vier minister haben ihre
politik komplett verändern das muss viel
mehr getan werden diesem land um
arbeitsplätze zu sichern um wohlstand zu
generieren um dem klimawandel zu
begegnen und da es unser programm an
sondervermögen notfalls zumal mit 100
milliarden eine richtige antwort auf
eine andere antwort wie nur der
waffenindustrie zu helfen denn diese
zukunftsinvestition sind die falschen
und dann zum schluss
wir glauben auch dass die
wirtschaftlichen schockwellen in diesem
jahr noch groß sein werden deshalb ist
schon jetzt richtig und wichtig dass
die das signal setzen dass kurzarbeit
die richtige antwort sein kann deshalb
muss die kurzarbeit ausgedehnt werden
bis mindestens ende des jahres vielen
dank mitarbeiter
der kollege reinhard houben hat das wort
für die fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
am 13.04 rechner haben sie gegenüber dpa
das vorliegende sofortprogramm für
unternehmen und beschäftigte
platziert vorgelegt haben sie den antrag
aber erst knapp zwei wochen später
nämlich gestern bei einem sofortprogramm
sollte man doch eigentlich erwarten dass
es auch sofort vorgelegt wird aber spaß
beiseite
als ich in den antrag gelesen habe was
da so alles drinsteht habe ich mir die
frage gestellt
verfolgt die cdu/csu eigentlich die
arbeit der bundesregierung
hat denn seit der pressemitteilung
anfang april niemand mehr diesen antrag
gegengelesen
geschaut ob bestimmte maßnahmen die
gefordert werden nicht schon längst
erledigt sind und
ich werde ja oft kommen
anders kann ich es mir ehrlich gesagt
nicht erklären dass sie eine temporäre
unterstützung für besonders von der
krise betroffenen unternehmen fordern
sie fordern durch schafften garantien
und kredite darlehen und ein kfw
programm und wenn sie am 13 04 dieses
papier ankündigen aber am achter vierten
die minister lindner und habe
entsprechend schon mit maßnahmen in die
öffentlichkeit geht muss ich schon die
frage stellen wer hat denn ihr papier
geschrieben und hat das nicht
kontrolliert und
außerdem meine damen und herren die
überbrückungshilfe 4 steht doch
weiterhin zur verfügung auch darauf
nehmen sie keinen bezug in ihrem papier
weiter hinten im papier steht dann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die zukunft einer gasversorgung die
nicht von gasimporten aus russland
abhängig ist und unsere souveränität
gewährleistet ja meine damen und herren
was macht denn die bundesregierung wo
war denn bitteschön minister habe der
war doch in katar hat sich darum
gekümmert
lng ports werden jetzt gebaut also sie
müssen ihre papiere schon irgendwie an
die politische wirklichkeit anpassen
sonst sind sie eben nicht glaubwürdig
und
dann sprechen sie das thema
digitalisierung an dadurch besonders
viel freude
darf ich zu ende ausführen frau kollegin
glöckner ja
es ist in den letzten jahren viel
besprochen wurden über
diversifizierung und es ist viel über
digitalisierung gesprochen worden und
wenn sie mal ihr forderungskatalog ihres
antrages angucke dann
sehen sie alle forderungen von punkt a
bis punkte sind im koalitionsvertrag
gesetzt und dann frage ich mich dass sie
nach vier monaten erwarten bei einem
thema was uns seit einem jahrzehnt
beschäftigt dass sie dann sofortige
ergebnisse erwarten ist politisch an der
stelle einfach ebenfalls unsäglich
die bundesregierung und besonders
minister wissing ist bei diesem thema
unterwegs und wir werden ergebnisse in
dieser ampel sicherlich vorlegen können
aber wie gesagt nicht zwingend nach vier
monaten das halte ich auch nach ihren
regierungs ergebnissen der letzten 16
jahren auch ein bisschen schwierig
ausgerechnet jetzt zu sagen jetzt muss
alles ganz schnell also zusammengenommen
bitte setzen sie sich doch mit der
politischen situation
auseinander prüfen sie was die regierung
macht und was sie nicht macht und kommen
dann mit einem etwas schmaleren papier
wo dann vielleicht wirklich vernünftige
kritikpunkte sind wieder auf uns zu dann
können wir gerne darüber diskutieren
seriöse oppositionsarbeit sieht
jedenfalls nicht so aus wie ein
sammelsurium von schönen forderungen die
man scheinbar aus den
unterschiedlichsten quellen
abgeschrieben hat und eine bemerkung zur
linken
das ist mehr so nüssel 2.0 was sie hier
vorgelegt haben das einzige was mir noch
gefehlt hat in ihrem antrag dass dann
auch das tempolimit eingebracht hätten
das haben sie nun leider nicht getan
deswegen können wir auch ihrem antrag
nicht zum stück vielen dank
vielen dank reinhard jugendwartes und
bären seiner rede gab es einen wechsel
im bundestagspräsidium die
sitzungsleitung hat jetzt wolfgang
kubicki der bundestags- vizepräsident
der namentlichen abstimmung bekannt
geben auf das ja alle warten über den
antrag der fraktionen spd cdu csu
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
frieden und freiheit in europa
verteidigen umfassende unterstützung für
die ukraine drucker 20
1550 abgegebene stimmen karten 693 mit
ja haben gestimmt
586 mit nein haben bestimmt 100
enthaltungen 7 der antrag ist damit
angenommen und wolfgang kubicki hat
sozusagen mitgebracht wird das ergebnis
zu der abstimmung über den gemeinsamen
antrag der ampel fraktionen zusammen mit
der größten opposition der
cdu/csu-fraktion da ging es ja unter
anderem unterstützung für die ukraine um
ein signal zu senden und auch um die
weitere lieferung von schweren waffen
dieser antrag hat keine bindende wirkung
er ist sozusagen unterstützung für die
bundesregierung und soll vor allem ein
signal richtung ukraine senden und ist
hier ja mit sehr großer mehrheit
angenommen und dem zugestimmt worden so
jetzt geht es aber weiter hier in der
aussprache
ist ja geht um hilfe für unternehmen es
spricht jetzt sebastian bremen für die
unionsfraktion
zielgerichtet und gut geholfen durch die
korona hilfen durch das kurzarbeitergeld
und die kurzarbeitergeldregelung durch
kfw kredite und anderes so dass wir
eigentlich gemeinsam im betrieblichen
bereich gut aus der krise herauskommen
nun kommen aber neue belastungen dazu
lieferengpässe fachkräftemangel stark
gestiegene preise und natürlich der
ukraine konflikt und alle ihre
bisherigen maßnahmen liegen kolleginnen
kollegen von der ampel zielen eigentlich
nur auf den privaten bereich im
unternehmerischen bereich erhoben ich
weiß nicht was sie da vor ihnen
angekündigt haben ich weiß nicht was in
diesem bereich sie gemacht hätten um die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
wirtschaft jetzt zu kurbeln und
investitionen voranzutreiben
sie machen in diesem bereich derzeit gar
nichts liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich möchte mal zwei punkte
zwei punkte herausgreifen
aus unserem sehr umfangreichen antrag
die sich sofort umsetzen könnten und die
natürlich auch geeint werden das eine
ist abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
finanzminister linden hat im wahlkampf
und auch jetzt immer die turbo
abschreibung 100% sofortabschreibung
übrigens zur fortschreibung heißt sie
müssen es auch sofort durchsetzen
vielleicht sie haben sie angekündigt es
ist nichts vorgelegt das würde
investitionen ankurbeln und würde
übrigens liquidität schaffen und würde
auch sich selber finanzieren weil es
reine verschiebung effekten lieber
kollege herr brandt sie haben das ja
selber beantragte auch in der letzten
periode übrigens die grünen auch der
bundesfinanzminister sagt er will es
machen wahrscheinlich will die spd nicht
setzen sie es durch und setzten sie
diese turbo abschreibung endlich um
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
und ein zweiter bereich der steuerliche
verluste rück trag- und der steuerliche
verlustvortrag auch hier gibt es aus der
letzten periode übrigens ist es
gescheitert damals an der spd gibt es
umfangreiche anträge von grünen und von
gelb und von uns den steuerlichen
verlust rücktritt zu verlängern über
drei jahre also über die krisenjahre
hinaus bis zu 2000 19 und den
verlustvortrag nicht einzuschränken wir
jetzt eingeschränkt wird auch das wäre
eine maßnahme die wir gemeinsam
durchsetzen könnten die grünen haben es
gefordert die fdp hat gefordert die cdu
csu gefordert der bundesfinanzministers
gefordert wahrscheinlich scheitert es an
der spd aber es könnten wir gemeinsam
durchsetzen auch das ist finanzierbar
als eine reine verschiebung ist von
steuersubstrat von einem jahr in das
andere sofort machbar könnten sie tun
sie sind jetzt in der regierung die
anträge die sie damals gestellt haben
interessieren sie anscheinend nicht mehr
und liebe kolleginnen kollegen genau das
wäre die maßgabe jetzt schnell helfen
indem man liquidität schafft den
unternehmen durch abschreibungen durch
verlustverrechnung aus eigener kraft
liquidität schaffen der unternehmen aus
eigener kraft und liquidität schafft
wachstum denn wir brauchen jetzt
wachstumsimpulse für den deutschen
mittelstand und für die deutsche
wirtschaft liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und wenn sie es nicht tun und wenn sie
es nicht tun legen sie die axt an die
deutsche wirtschaft an und an den
wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres
mittelstandes deswegen kann ich sie nur
auffordern nehmen sie die anträge die
sich selber gestellt haben in der
letzten periode ernst und setzen sie es
jetzt um sie haben jetzt die möglichkeit
nicht nur reden sondern wirklich jetzt
auch handeln handeln ist jetzt das gebot
der stunde ihre kollegin kollegen wir
sind gern bereit in den beratungen
miteinander zu sprechen und uns hier
auszutauschen damit wir diese punkte
wenigstens gemeinsam umsetzen können
herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege bremen
[Applaus]
nächstes der kollege sebastian roloff
spd fraktion
vielen dank herr präsident meine damen
und herren ich habe wir haben ja heute
schon viel über konstruktive
oppositionsarbeit gehört und gesprochen
und ich habe eine halbe stunde zugehört
und hat manchmal mehrmals auf die
tagesordnung geguckt ich habe
verzweifelt das sofortprogramm über das
wir reden gesucht ich hab es nicht
gefunden es liegt zumindest nicht vor
kann liegen aber bei klöckner es sieht
eher so aus als hätte da jemand eine
festplatte aufgeräumt und alles was man
irgendwo noch gefunden hätte
zusammenkopiert und rausgeschickt aber
es ist kein sofortprogramm weil ich
erkläre ihnen auch gerne gleich warum es
ist nämlich mit lichten groß dass alles
und förderung style falsches die
einleitung ist korrekt wir stehen vor
riesigen herausforderungen
transformation nach chur wird jetzt
natürlich auch die frage ukraine und die
entsprechenden folgen die analyse ist
richtig und sie teilweise auch wichtige
beschlüsse oder forderungen auf der
einen seite sind vorgaben zum beispiel
dass mir ein besonderes paar
maßnahmenpaket für besonders von der
krise betroffene unternehmen machen oder
für energieintensive unternehmen wollen
ihr müsst das haben wir schon gemacht
weiß nichts können sie natürlich fordern
es ist schon lange auf den weg gebracht
genauso beim thema bürokratie sie
fordern ein neues bürokratie
entlastungsgesetz find ich ganz
bezaubernd sind wir dafür sind wir in
der erstellung ist schon auf dem weg
genauso wie das unternehmensbasis
register und natürlich die
beschleunigung von planungs und
genehmigungsprozesse da sind wir total
mit ihnen auch anna linien das problem
ist nur hätte dieses antrags nicht
bedurft sondern es ist schon auf dem weg
beim bürokratieabbau ist aus unserer
sicht aber klar dass das natürlich ein
selbstzweck ist auf der einen seite auf
der anderen seite ist aber natürlich
nicht dazu führen darf dass soziale und
ökologische standards abgebaut werden
dementsprechend werden wir da sehr genau
hinschauen im ziel sind er aber vereint
dann und das finde ich noch viel
charmanter fordern sie sachen die sie
selber jahrelang verhindert haben
verbesserung der fachkräfte an werbung
zum beispiel wollen die unternehmen
schon immer wollte auch die spd
nachweislich in der letzten regierung
immer haben sie immer verhindert finden
sie auf einmal toll finden wir gut dass
es da einen lernprozess gab es aber auch
fraglich ob das mit einem sofortprogramm
einhergeht themen die frauenerwerbsquote
oder so diskutieren sie gar nicht das
finde ich auch immer einigermaßen
verstörend und bei der frage
beschleunigung beim aufbau von digitaler
infrastruktur muss man nur die namen
dobrindt und scheuer sagen und dann
festhalten wer da ganz offensichtlich
gebremst hat und dass das ganz
offensichtlich nicht an und zwar in der
letzten regierung
und es wird aber leider noch schlimmer
deswegen sie ahnen dass wir ihrem
sofortprogramm ihrem angeblichen
wahrscheinlich nicht zustimmen werden
ich fordere auch unverantwortliche dinge
und da habe ich ihnen sehr genau
zugehört vor klöckner wie sie über das
belastungs moratorium gesprochen haben
es wundert mich ein bisschen der kollege
altmaier hat da vor kurzem relativ breit
schiffbruch erlitten dementsprechend
habe ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden
warum sie daraus nichts gelernt haben
und da nicht einen schritt weiter sind
weil völlig klar ist dass die die die
fortschritte die man blick auf
lieferketten und nachhaltigkeit erreicht
hat nicht einfach durch ein
belastungsmoratorium einerseits wieder
einkassieren kann es auch gar nicht
wirkt also reden sie da mal gerne mit
kollegen altmaier dann sehen sie dass
das nicht funktioniert und herr kollege
bringen wir sind ja beide aus bayern
wenn sie in diesem sofortprogramm auch
den weiterbetrieb von kernkraftwerken
fordern kann ich können wir gerne mal
auf unseren ministerpräsidenten zu gehen
der hinterhand näher bei ihnen in
nürnberg als bei mir der uns ja immer
erklärt atomkraft ist super aber
endlager in bayern geht gar nicht
erneuerbare energien sind prinzipiell
schon ganz okay aber abstand brauchen
wir 10h regelung und eigentlich waren es
dann wieder so schwer wie möglich machen
also da ist viel kokolores dabei so
deutlich muss ich sagen und wer zur
frage ob atomkraftwerke jetzt in der
situation noch weiter laufen sollten mir
nicht glaubt oder der regierung nicht
glaubt kann sich ja immer die
entsprechenden fachgutachten verlassen
da sind sie leider auf einem irrweg und
es wäre schön wenn sie von dem wieder
runterkommen
schließlich
sind da aber auch wieder beieinander
wenn wir darüber sprechen dass den
milliarden-programmen
steuererleichterungen brauchen auch
steuersenkungen gegebenenfalls für eine
gesunde wirtschaft klar ist aber auch
dass wir dann ein riesenproblem
bundeshaushalt haben und da könnte man
sich jetzt natürlich auch mal darüber
unterhalten auch die schuldenbremse so
eine gute idee war da sind wir uns in
der regierung auch noch nicht ganz einig
aber wir haben uns immerhin auf eine
aussetzung verständigt klar ist aber
auch dass dieser investitionsbedarf
irgendwo herkommen muss und dazu sagen
sie auch nichts außer dass sie wohl
keine forderungen stellen ich darf zum
abschluss alle kolleginnen und kollegen
der union die einer konstruktiven
mitarbeit interessiert sind herzlich
einladen diese mit uns im
wirtschaftsausschuss zu führen das
funktioniert ja teilweise auch ganz gut
es ist in der öffentlichkeit im moment
ein bisschen er trump würde ich das so
sagen darf aber vielleicht kommen sie
von dem trip wieder runter herr merz hat
geradezu aber wir würden sie auch nicht
verraten wenn sie sich in den fragen
dann als enten und konstruktiv mit uns
über themen reden das heute hilft leider
nicht weiter vielen dank
[Applaus]
als nächster redner das wort der kollege
dr malte kaufmann eine archivfunktion
erster obmann im wirtschaftsausschuss
für die afg
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
nach 16 jahren regierung merkel mit
teils verheerenden auswirkungen auf den
standort deutschland
fordert die union nun ein sofortprogramm
für die wirtschaft besser spät als nie
könnte man sagen
die antrag liebe kollegen von der union
ist ein rundumschlag um vieles anzugehen
was jahrelang von ihnen versäumt wurde
beispielsweise wollen sie endlich die
öffentliche verwaltung digitalisieren
und modernisieren das wollen wir als ard
auch und zwar schon lange
auch viele anderen andere ihrer
vorschläge wirken wie bei uns
abgeschrieben beispielsweise der
überfällige bürokratieabbau viele ihrer
forderungen sind aus unserer sicht also
wichtig und dennoch ihr ganzer antrag
macht den eindruck als wollten sie nur
an ein paar einzelnen stellschrauben
drehen um die wirklich großen probleme
unserer zeit dagegen machen sie einen
weiten bogen
so rufen sie jetzt beispielsweise nach
einer ich zitiere sicheren bezahlbaren
und souveränen energieversorgung das ist
richtig aber der entscheidende zweite
satz fehlt er müsste lauten eine
energieversorgung also wie wir sie
früher hatten bevor eine unionsgeführte
bundesregierung in einer nacht und
nebelaktion die sichere und
grundlastfähige kernkraft abgeschafft
hat und dann auch noch den ausstieg aus
der kohleverstromung beschlossen hat um
beides gegen unzuverlässigen flattr
strom aus wind und sonne einzutauschen
das wäre mut zur wahrheit liebe kollegen
immerhin schlagen sie vor man solle den
weiterbetrieb von kernkraftwerken prüfen
ich frage sie was gibt es denn da jetzt
noch zu prüfen angesichts der aktuellen
dramatischen versorgungslage und der
immer näher rückenden energiekrise
natürlich müssen die meiler am netz
bleiben was denn sonst
weiterhin fordern sie die verminderung
der energiepreise durch
steuerentlastungen
was sie dagegen nicht sagen ihre co2
steuer ist es doch die die preise an den
tankstellen ganz bewusst und permanent
nach oben treiben soll diese steuer muss
weg ersatzlos
das aber meine damen und herren das aber
fordern sie nicht warum damit würden sie
ja zugeben dass die links grüne politik
der ära merkel ein großer fehler war in
ihrem antrag stehen viele gute sachen
und bestritten aber das große ganze
fehlt die fatalen fehler der letzten
jahre werden nicht benannt und nicht
korrigiert deshalb werden wir uns
enthalten vielen herzlichen dank
sagen meinte kaufmann für die afg
fraktion
und katharina becker erwarten wir jetzt
hier am rednerpult die finanzpolitische
sprecherin der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe fraktionen auf der
cdu/csu ich möchte mich als erstes noch
mal bedanken dass wir heute gemeinsam
verantwortung übernommen haben als
deutschland gegenüber der ukraine
vielen dank
und es geht jetzt darum wie wir hier im
rahmen dieser krisen aber auch anderer
krisen helfen unserem land unseren
beschäftigten unseren unternehmen
unserer wirtschaft die deutsche
bundesregierung macht mit dem
entlastungspaket 12 steuerquote steuer
hilfe gesetz mit
wirtschaftshilfen in unfassbarer
größenordnung in bezug auf kredite aber
auch mit zuschüssen ein riesiges angebot
ein riesiges paket und parallel geben
wir noch
zukunftsorientierung wenn die zukunft
dieses kontinents und dieses landes ist
energie unabhängig und mit
siebenmeilenstiefeln schön dass sie da
sind kein minister gehen wir hier voran
in die energieunabhängigkeit und mit
eine prosperierende grüne zukunft darauf
freuen wir uns das ist der fortschritt
dieser ampel
bei den maßnahmen die wir vorliegen ein
sammelsurium wurde ja schon geschrieben
musste ich direkt bei der ersten erst
mal schmunzeln wir haben ja gerade die
degressive abschreibung beschlossen ein
großes paket mit zehn milliarden
belastungen über die nächsten vier jahre
entlastung für die unternehmen belastung
für den haushalt wir haben uns geeinigt
auf eine super abschreibung und sie
steigt und schlagen jetzt noch eine
turbo abschreibung vor wobei sie selber
auch bei der degressiven afa völlig
dabei waren das ist ein lustiges wort
spiel aber kein wesentlicher beitrag zur
debatte bei der umsatzsteuer da fordern
sie diverse entlastungen und behaupten
das würde dass verbraucher klima
unterstützen dabei wissen wir alle
umsatz steuersenkungen haben nicht
unbedingt diesen effekt die preise
werden sie unbedingt weiter gegeben das
ist nicht zielgerichtet das sind nochmal
kosten energie steuersenkung stromsteuer
senkungen all das kostet und hat noch
nicht mal mehr die lenkungswirkung die
wir uns wünschen denn das sind mengen
anreize und wir müssen doch gerade heute
er eben anders wirtschaften und nicht
mehr einfach nur an energie verbrauchen
und das sind einfach die falschen dinge
ihre maßnahmen führen leider zu weiterer
marktverzerrung auch zwischen großen und
kleinen setzen die falschen anreiz und
haben nicht kalkulierbare kosten das
geht gegen solide finanzen was sie
selber eigentlich fordern
und erschütternd an ihre analyse finde
ich
dass das thema klima gar nicht vorkommt
sie waren bestimmt auch schon mal in
davos und die top-3 risiken der
weltwirtschaft jedem januar publiziert
wurden mit klimawandel lieferengpässen
dadurch wegen schlimm wetterereignissen
zu tun und sie geben doch immer vor so
nah an der wirtschaft zu sein das sind
die dinge die da auch extrem bewegen und
deswegen kann man gerade jetzt nicht es
so verkaufen als wäre es ein
belastungsmoratorium sondern es ist eine
entlastung für unternehmen wirklich
klarheit an den kapitalmärkten haben mit
sustainable finance maßnahmen wohin denn
das geld fließen soll denn wir brauchen
die privaten investitionen und so kann
auch wieder prosperität entstehen und
ich bitte sie kommen sie bitte an mit
uns im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert die
zukunft ist beschrieben der fortschritt
den wir wollen und wir arbeiten da gerne
konstruktiv miteinander aber nicht mit
nicht wirksam sammelsurium an maßnahmen
die einfach nicht die richtigen effekte
haben vielen dank
vielen dank frau kollegin möglich
[Applaus]
als nächster redner das wort der kollege
markus herbrand fdp fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe kollegen
der cdu
also um einen innovationspreis sollten
sie sich mit diesem antrag wirklich
nicht bewerben alles aber auch wirklich
alles was hier niedergeschrieben steht
gibt oder gab es in irgendeiner form
schon beantragt ist ein sammelsurium an
plagiaten die sie von allen seiten
regelrecht schamlos kopiert haben
ich habe auch fdp forderungen darin
gefunden das gebe ich zu auf der suche
nach neuen bin ich dann auch fündig
geworden wie die kollegen gesagt hat die
turbo abschreibung aber auch nur auf den
ersten blick denn auf den zweiten blick
müssen wir sagen selbst das haben wir in
teilen schon wenn wir nur an die
digitalen wirtschaftsgüter denken die
wir im augenblick ja auch schon mit
einer nutzungsdauer unterstellte
nutzungsdauer von einem jahr sehr
schnell abschreiben so schnell wie es
eigentlich nur geht
aber wir sehen hier eben auch klar und
deutlich was wir als ampel anders
vorhaben wir wollen gezielt und
eben nicht mit der gießkanne sondern
eher mit der spritze die identifizierten
probleme fördern die digitalisierung und
die dekarbonisierung bekämpfen das sind
probleme die sie uns ja auch
hinterlassen haben und wir haben uns im
koalitionsvertrag darauf verständigt
dass gezielt anzugehen und eben diese
super afa auf
den weg zu bringen entschuldigung auf
den weg zu bringen und herr kollege
umsehen oder auch ich glaube frau
klöckner hat auch gesagt warum kommt sie
nicht warum kommt sie nicht sämtliche
spitzenverbände der deutschen wirtschaft
haben gesagt dass das im augenblick
eigentlich gar nicht die richtige zeit
dafür seien visa also diese super in
anspruch zu nehmen
und man muss einfach auch mal festhalten
dass nicht jede maßnahme immer zu jedem
zeitpunkt richtig ist und wir werden das
machen und übrigens wirkt die ampel auch
schon an anderer stelle für april
schritt für schritt verfolgen wir unsere
ziele und zeigen auch die notwendige
flexibilität dabei wenn das wirklich
notwendig ist weil die super aber noch
nicht kommt verlängern wir jetzt gerade
die degressive afa auch das ist eine
sehr gute und wichtige regelung um
weitere investitionen anzuheizen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
es hier nicht nur mit einem plagiat zu
tun es ist auch noch eine märchen liste
märchen nicht deshalb weil die
vorschläge nicht in teilen sehr sinnvoll
lernen sondern weil für deren umsetzung
die sterne als silbertaler nur so vom
himmel fallen müssten möglicherweise
besser sogar als gold
insofern fehlt es sowohl der langen
liste als auch der union an zwei
aspekten es mangelt zum einen an der
staatlichen an statischen
verantwortungsbewusstsein die lage wegen
der unten ukraine krise wegen corona
wegen der inflationären wirkungen ist in
der tat sehr ernst mit solchen kopierten
antrag anträgen zeigen sie dass sie die
situation nicht angemessen ernst nehmen
und zum anderen wenn man forderungen in
milliardenhöhe aufstellt dann muss man
auch sagen woher die mittel kommen
sollen wie paradox dass sie sich
gleichzeitig als seriöse haushälter
profitieren möchten und auf der anderen
seite viele milliarden ausgaben fordern
und nicht ansatzweise sagen wo das geld
herkommen soll
und schließlich gar nicht ihnen auch
nicht ersparen den ein oder anderen
vorschlag haben sie selber ja hier schon
seit jahren formuliert sie bleiben uns
schuldig weshalb sie in den letzten 16
jahren diese forderung selbst nie
umgesetzt haben es kommen ja noch redner
der union vielleicht könnte man das mal
aufklären um der versachlichung hier
genüge zu tun liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ein solcher antrag wird der
aktuellen krise situation nicht gerecht
und deshalb ist es auch gut dass wir
heute direkt darüber abstimmen und kann
ausschussberatung mehr dafür verwenden
herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege herein
[Applaus]
nun hat sich das wort der kollege
hansjörg durz cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren
wenn millionen von menschen eine
politische gemeinschaft bilden dann
braucht es ein narrativ eine erzählung
die aus ganz vielen ich sein wir machen
und dabei spielt in deutschland des
wohlstands versprechen eine zentrale
rolle vom wirtschaftswunder bis zum
exportweltmeister wirtschaftlicher
erfolg ist ein kernelement unserer dna
mit den worten eines amerikanischen
polit strategen könnte man
zusammenfassen
economy stupid
und das muss man diese bundesregierung
tatsächlich auch noch mal deutlich sagen
eine regierung die ein entlastungspaket
beschließt ohne jegliche entlastung für
unternehmen das kann nicht sein
die wirtschaftsmacht deutschland gerät
zunehmend unter druck nach zwei corona
jahren und der hoffnung auf mehr
normalität und wirtschaftlicher erholung
belasten der angriffskrieg russlands
gestörte lieferketten und die inflation
die bilanz so dass sämtliche
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute und auch
die bundesregierung ihre
wirtschaftsprognosen spürbar senken
mussten
kurzfristige hilfsmaßnahmen für
unternehmen sind absolut richtig und
wichtigste sind die notversorgung akuter
beschwerden was wir aber auch dringend
brauchen ist ein langfristiges
fitnessprogramm und deswegen muss unser
wirtschaftsminister nicht nur
notfallsanitäter sein sondern auch
fitnesstrainer
während unter der krone krise vor allem
der dienstleistungssektor litt stellen
die aktuellen herausforderungen
die deutsche industrie vor große
probleme und damit einen der wohlstands
garanten unseres landes für diesen ist
bezahlbarer energie elementar wir alle
wissen aber dass die energiekosten in
den nächsten jahren tendenziell eher
weiter steigen werden und umso wichtiger
ist es dass wir unsere
wettbewerbsfähigkeit insgesamt deutlich
verbessern so schnell wie möglich meine
damen und herren unser ziel muss sein
dass wir in deutschland die besten
rahmenbedingungen für gründer und
unternehmer haben
das fitnessprogramm für die wirtschaft
dass wir mit diesem antrag vorlegen
beinhaltet eben nicht nur forderungen
die geld kosten wie vorher mehrfach
angeflogen gelungen ist sondern vor
allem auch maßnahmen die die
rahmenbedingungen verbessern um
unternehmen das bestehen im wettbewerb
zu ermöglichen
und wachstum generieren drei elemente
möchte ich herausgreifen erstens die
bundesregierung der auf die wirtschaft
nicht weiter mit paragraphen und
vorschriften gängeln übrigens auch nicht
durch aktuelle gesetzgebung da besteht
nämlich auch große gefahr darin
unternehmen brauchen luft zum atmen wir
verschreiben der wirtschaft eine
bürokratie diät und ganz kurzfristig die
unternehmen brauchen ein
belastungsmoratorium
zweitens
der staat muss schneller agiler und
digitaler werden
endlos lange planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren bremsen dynamik
und innovation das sehen wir alle so
als union haben wir aber 2017 das online
zugangs gesetz auf den weg gebracht
sämtliche dienstleistungen der
öffentlichen hand müssen bis ende diesen
jahres bis ende 2022 digital zur
verfügung gestellt werden mit dem
zukunftspaket haben wir zusätzliche
milliarden mitte 20 20 für die umsetzung
zur verfügung gestellt das heißt die
voraussetzungen sind geschaffen von der
register modernisierung bis zum
digitalen unternehmens konto jetzt muss
die bundesregierung einfach nur umsetzen
und drittens gerade in dieser zeit wird
deutlich dass wir partner in der welt
brauchen politisch aber auch
wirtschaftlich des freihandels abkommen
mit kanada liegt auf dem tisch wir legen
es in jeder sitzungswoche wieder auf dem
tisch eine stimme für täter ist in der
stimme für wohlstand und eine stimme für
den zusammenhalt in der westlichen welt
wirklich stimmen sie diesen abkommen zu
vielen dank
sein kollege lutz
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin lene
gerne spd-fraktion lena werner von der
spd mitglied im wirtschaftsausschuss für
die spd bundestagsfraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe 9b des thomas
morus gymnasium aus meinem wahlkreis um
auf der tribüne die unionsfraktion haben
wir das gleiche verständnis von dem wort
sofort laut duden bedeutet es innerhalb
kürzester zeit und ohne weitere
verzögerung wenn ich mir jetzt ihren
antrag anschaue dann stellt sich mir die
frage wie all die maßnahmen die sicher
teilweise auch richtig sind unverzüglich
umgesetzt werden sollen die antrag liegt
auch keine sofortmaßnahmen fest hier
finden wir fast das gesamte wahlprogramm
der union und teilweise sogar vorhaben
die sie versuchen seit jahren
mit vielen jahre feststellung stimme ich
überein die korona pandemie bedeutet
weiterhin eine belastung für viele
unternehmen dazu kommen nun die
auswirkungen des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die energieversorgung
und die lieferketten wir müssen alles
daran setzen die belastung für die
menschen und auch die unternehmen in der
aktuellen lage so gut gering wie möglich
zu halten und wir stehen vor einem
jahrzehnt der wirtschaftlichen
transformation wobei ich in diesem punkt
nicht ganz überein stimmen denn die
transformation hat bereits begonnen
wer von der spd bundestagsfraktion sowie
die bundesregierung arbeiten bereits mit
hochdruck an all diesen punkten um die
unternehmen und beschäftigten sofort zu
entlasten
in ihrem antrag lassen sie komplett
außen vor das bereits maßnahmen auf den
weg gebracht worden da sie uns hier eine
sehr lange liste vorgelegt haben möchte
ich jetzt nur auf wenige punkte eingehen
und diese klar stellen sie fordern unter
anderem temporäre unterstützung für
besonders von der krise betroffenen
unternehmen genau darauf hat man sich
doch in der bundesregierung bereits
geeinigt für unternehmen die vom
russischen angriffskrieg und dessen
folgen betroffen sind steht bereits ein
umfassendes maßnahmenpaket zur verfügung
mit dem kfw kreditprogramm und dem
bürgschaftsprogramm werden schnelle
liquiditätshilfen für unternehmen
sichergestellt diese maßnahmen können
schon in dieser bzw in der nächsten
woche starten einen direkten zuschuss zu
den stromkosten können die unternehmen
beantragen die von deutlich gestiegenen
energiekosten betroffen sind im
härtesten frei erhalten betroffene
unternehmen bis zu 50 millionen euro an
zuschüssen zur strom- und gaskosten
alleine diese maßnahme wird
voraussichtlich einen umfang von bis zu
sechs milliarden euro haben zu behaupten
die wirtschaft finde in den
leistungspaketen kaum berücksichtigung
ist deswegen schlichtweg falsch
im tätiger des antrags fordern sie
außerdem ein sofortprogramm für
beschäftigte mit den leistungspaketen
der ampelkoalition von februar/märz
sorgen wir bereits für massive
entlastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger und das nicht nur bei den
energiekosten nur heute nur noch heute
werden wir über den wegfall der
eeg-umlage entscheiden und somit werden
ab dem ersten juli alle verbraucher
indirekt und unverzüglich entlastet
darüber hinaus wurden massive
steuerentlastung beschlossen hinzu kommt
eine erhöhung des
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags sowie der
pendlerpauschale und einmalzahlungen für
beschäftigte über 300 euro um für
direkte und schnelle entlastungen zu
sorgen dass ein euro ticket für den öpnv
steht für jede bürgerin und jeden bürger
ab dem ersten juni zur verfügung und ja
ich gehe auch davon aus dass dies im
ländlichen raum aktiv genutzt wird aus
meinem wahlkreis bitburg habe ich schon
von vielen gehört die das angebot sehr
gerne nutzen wollen zu guter letzt
schließlich auch eine absenkung der
energie steuer auf kraftstoffe an die
maßnahmen an dies sind konkrete
entlastungen von denen die verbraucher
innen direkt und unmittelbar profitieren
wir müssen zukunftsfähige soziale und
vor allem nachhaltige wirtschaftspolitik
machen als junger mensch einer
generation die bisher in jeglicher weise
hinsichtlich sicherheit gelebt hat bin
ich mir der verantwortung die wir für
unser land haben mehr als bewusst
besonders durch den russischen
angriffskrieg in der ukraine stehen wir
jetzt vor der großen herausforderung
unser land unsere gesellschaft und
unsere wirtschaft in eine neue zeit zu
führen dass wir nicht so weitermachen
können wie bisher wird nicht mehr allein
durch die klimakrise getrieben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen was wir
brauchen ist weitsicht eine
differenzierte analyse der
herausforderung und passgenaue lösung
ich danke daher der bundesregierung für
die bereits auf den weg gebrachten
maßnahmen für die bevölkerung und
unternehmen die sofort helfen
insbesondere in der aktuellen situation
ist eine konstruktive und
zielorientierte oppositionsarbeit
besonders wichtig anträge die dieser
helfen dabei nicht weiter es geht um
unsere zukunft vielen dank
vielen dank
es war ja zügig achten letztlich sehe
sie doch als nächste hat das wort der
parlamentarische staatssekretär michael
kellner für die bundesregierung hätte
sie schon vermisst weil auf der
regierungsbank diese nie erwartet hätte
nicht selten ist wir sehen danke
ich hab sie hinter ihrer maske nicht
nicht deutlich erkennbar danke herr
präsident sehr geehrte damen und herren
wir sind eine koalition die handelt und
handel den zeichen wo die wirtschaft
belastet ist immer noch von den
nachwirkungen von der korona pandemie
und jetzt von dem brutalen krieg
russlands in der ukraine lasst mich
sagen was handeln heißt wir schaffen zum
ersten juli die eeg umlage ab davon
profitiert der handwerker auf dem land
genauso wie der händler in der
innenstadt
mit dem oster paket machen wir es für
unternehmen attraktiver selber in ihren
betriebsstätten in grünen strom zu
investieren wir nehmen dort die abgaben
runter wir nehmen dort die bürokratie
runter das hilft gerade dem mittelstand
dem rückgrat unserer wirtschaft also der
nächste punkt und den behandeln
voraussichtlich nächste woche starten
wir mit dem kfw kreditprogramm und ein
wirtschaftsprogramm um liquidität der
unternehmen liquidität zu sichern die
durch die ukraine krise unverschuldet in
schwierigkeiten gekommen sind und wir
machen ein neues zuschussprogramm zur
temporären kostendämpfung des
preisanstieges bei erdgas und strom für
energieintensive unternehmen die im
internationalen wettbewerb stehen circa
4.000 unternehmen 5 milliarden euro
damit erhalten wir die internationale
wettbewerbsfähigkeit
damit dämpfen wir den schock wir können
aber dass wir das auch klar sagen wir
können nicht alle preissteigerungen
ausgleichen
wir helfen deswegen zielgerichtet dass
dieser krieg keine belastung keine
kosten für die deutsche gesellschaft für
die unternehmen für die wirtschaft mit
sich bringt das können wir nicht
versprechen dass ist nicht möglich und
das sollten wir auch so ehrlich sagen
wer meint es gäbe keine belastung das
ist doch der coup doch nicht in die welt
was da geschieht diese ehrlichkeit die
würde ich mir wünschen diversifizieren
die energieversorgung dass wir nie
wieder so abhängig sind wie wir es von
russland waren und teilweise sind ich
will mich wir machen uns auf den weg die
unternehmen machen sie einen weg stellen
ihre lieferketten um sie helfen
geflüchteten sie unterstützten die
sanktionen dafür danke ich ihnen recht
herzlich wir legen gemeinsam einfahrt
heraus aus der fatalen abhängigkeit
müssen schneller werden mit der
dekarbonisierung mit der sozial
ökologischen transformation
das liegt im interesse des klimaschutzes
interesse nationalen sicherheit und des
wirtschaftlichen wohlstands herzlichen
dank
michael kellner der parlamentarische
staatssekretär beim bundesministerium
für wirtschaft und klimaschutz er hat
noch mal gesagt wir als bundesregierung
helfen zielgerichtet dass dieser krieg
eine ökonomische belastungen mit sich
bringt das können wir nicht versprechen
wir können die belastung nur ablehnen
gitta connemann jetzt für die cdu/csu
herr präsident meine damen und herren
eine wohnung urlaub
soziale sicherheit gute ausbildung für
kinder das wünschen sich alle am ende
wohlstand für alle
diesem ziel hat ludwig erhard
ist deutschland groß geworden sein
erfolgsmodell die soziale
marktwirtschaft freiheit und
verantwortung getragen von betrieben und
mitarbeitern
99 prozent davon sind mittelständler
handwerk handel gewerbe industrie das
rückgrat unserer gesellschaft motor für
innovation garant für arbeitsplätze und
ausbildung die übrigens nicht in
jahresabschlüssen denken sondern in
generationen die risiko und
verantwortung übernehmen die deshalb aus
unserer sicht der union ein recht auf
unser vertrauen auf unseren respekt
haben
das erleben sie häufig nicht das
unternehmerbild wird verzerrt wir haben
es hier aktuell erlebt in einer zeit in
der der mittelstand so viel schultert
übrigens sich auch bei den flüchtlingen
engagiert von krisen oder
kriegsgewinnler spricht das ist einfach
nur erbärmlich
abgabenlast arbeitskräftemangel
regulierungswahn das gehört zum alltag
zur wahrheit gehört wir als gruppe haben
dazu auch beigetragen
hier eine gesetz dort eine verordnung
der mittelstand konnte es aber schultern
bislang aber jetzt ist die schmerzgrenze
erreicht
pandemie krieg lockdown in shanghai
lieferketten die brechen rohstoffe
vielen preise explodieren inflation es
gibt keine planungssicherheit der
mittelstand kommt aus dem krisenmodus
nicht mehr heraus deshalb stehen wir am
rande einer rezession
deutschland hat viele krisen erlebt
wir können auch diese meistern aber nur
mit unseren unternehmerinnen und
unternehmern mit den mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern diese wissen wie es
geht und dafür brauchen sie keinen
amtsvormund liebe ampel sondern sie
brauchen einen befreiungsschlag
dafür legen wir ihnen ein
entwicklungspaket als union vor damit
der mittelstand seine kraft wieder frei
entfalten kann denn der wohlstand fällt
nicht vom himmel
dazu gehört den menschen etwas
zuzutrauen dafür brauchen wir einen
belastungsstopp ein bürokratie
moratorium national aber auch europäisch
auf der agenda der eu stehen zurzeit
dutzende von neuen reglementierungen
brüssel dts zum beispiel mit der
taxonomie vorgaben machen wer wann wo
investiert damit chris diskreditiert
auch die kommission übrigens die europa
idee und dabei brauchen wir gerade jetzt
europa mehr denn je wir brauchen dem
einsatz für offene märkte für
internationale frei das abkommen die
zeta die aussetzung hier scheitert an
der ampel und das ist unverantwortlich
für die exportnation deutschland
aber hier wird erkennbar aus
umverteilungsstaat wachstum gesetzt auch
hier in der debatte bestes schlechtes
beispiel ihre steuerpolitik stadt zu
entlasten wird kassiert bei sprit bei
strom jahr die ampel hat entlastung
angekündigt aber die mit r helfen kommen
zu spät und gehen mit paketen die in
ihrem energie preisgeld an rentnern
studenten mini-jobbern und übrigens dem
mittelstand vorbei den traum vom
eigenheim haben sie sowieso schon
geschrottet mit der mit der abschaffung
der förderung gehälter müssen mit der
inflation schritt halten können derzeit
wird aber der lohnausgleich vom start
weg gesteuert die amper sie zu kassiert
und verteilt dann um aber der staat ist
kein gut her die bürger und betriebe
brauchen keine almosen sondern sie
brauchen entlastung technologieoffenheit
statt ideologie eigenverantwortung statt
auflagen auch für digitale
transformation und energiewende nur dann
wird unser land seine
wettbewerbsfähigkeit bewahren und dafür
legen wir ihnen ein programm vor im
sinne dessen was ludwig erhard wollte
und möglich machte wohlstand für alle
herzlichen dank
gitta connemann endet mit ludwig erhard
das ist auch klar denn sie ist die
vorsitzende
mittelstandsvereinigung der union und
die cdu legt hier einen antrag vor
sofortprogramm für unternehmen und
beschäftigte und fordert darin unter
anderem ein belastungsmoratorium
steuerliche entlastungen zb ausgeweitete
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten steuerliche
verlustrechnung über die krisenjahre 20
ist 2 vielen aus jens bike für die spd
ich verstehe sie ihr ein stück weit wir
alle ja das ist hilft ihnen auch nicht
viel weiter ich weiß aber wir alle haben
wir das zdf politbarometer von anfang
april gesehen und wir alle haben gesehen
dass du noch 18 prozent der menschen in
diesem land bei union die größte
wirtschaftskompetenz vermuten
die menschen das zu tonnen ihre
wirtschaftspolitik verloren und
mittlerweile sehen sie vollkommen zu
recht da die größen kompetenzwerte auch
bei der spd und dann ist man bei der
opposition natürlich gefragt man muss
was tun und dann fängt man anträge zu
schreiben aber ich sage noch dieser
antrag wird ihnen da nicht helfen
sie fordern ernsthaft und weiterbetrieb
von atomkraftwerken zu prüfen da waren
sie schon mal weiter und auch das diw
deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung hat nochmal 2009 10
bekräftigt hat home kraft war nie eine
saubere kostengünstige energiequelle
wird es auch nicht sein
sie fordern dann eine neuauflage des
freihandels abkommen tipp ein
freihandelsabkommen mit dem unternehmen
auf vermeintlich entgangene gewinne
klagen sollen aber arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmerrechte gar keine rolle
spielten und da sind weite teile des
antrags man sagen kann liebe cdu csu die
90er jahre haben sich gemeldet sie
hätten gern ihre wirtschaftliche
programmatik zurück denn gute und
fortschrittliche wirtschafts und
arbeitsmarktpolitik muss zusammengedacht
werden
und obwohl ihr antrag die beschäftigten
im titel trägt finden die dem antrag der
gar nicht statt wir aber wissen die
wirtschaftliche erfolg anzunehmen es
hängt maßgeblich von seinen
beschäftigten ab und deswegen haben wir
auch und auch das findet keine erwähnung
die sonderregeln zum kurzarbeitergeld
verlängert aber der reicht hat zugang
der hütte leistung satz längere
bezugsdauer erstattung von
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
keine erwähnung wert
und obwohl ist das kriseninstrument
schlechthin war acht millionen menschen
haben so einen arbeitsplatz gerettet
bekommen und wir haben herr bremen hat
das angesprochen auch die
liquiditätsengpässe von unternehmen
überwunden und ihnen geholfen diese zu
überwinden aber auch das findet keine
erwähnung
auch nicht das ist ein internationales
vorbild war frankreich großbritannien
die usa haben es kopiert es war 2009
schon der garant für das deutsche
jobwunder all das findet keinen
unternehmen bei erwähnung und das ist
der grund warum die menschen
mittlerweile mehr vertrauen in unsere
wirtschaftspolitik haben als in ihre war
für uns klar ist gute
arbeitsmarktpolitik ist gute
wirtschaftspolitik beides geht nur
zusammen
für uns zählt der erhalt von
arbeitsplätzen für uns ist eine gute
lohnentwicklung wichtig denn gerade wenn
es export probleme gibt wenn wir
konjunkturelle flaute name ist wichtig
die binnennachfrage zu stärken und
deswegen gilt für uns die wirtschaft
dient in erster gehende menschen und
nicht umgekehrt und das werden wir dann
auch gleich sehen bei der beratung zum
gesetzentwurf über die mindestlohn in
höhe von 12 euro die folgt wenn sie uns
auch unterstützen möchte binnennachfrage
zu stärken gut die wirtschaftspolitik zu
machen dann stimmen sie diesem antrag
leicht zu und das möchte man sagen mit
dem vor dem wirtschafts helfen ja schon
erwähnt wurden dem kurzarbeitergeld
mindestlohn sichernde arbeitsplätze
helfen den unternehmen in deutschland
stärken die binnennachfrage und bringen
unser land durch die krise herzlichen
dank
jetzt zeigt er sozialdemokrat wies auf
den nächsten punkt hinten den der
bundestag beraten wird das flaggschiff
sozusagen der spd bemühungen 12 euro
mindestlohn aber das kommt erst nachher
im moment berät der bundestag hier ein
sofortprogramm für unternehmen und
beschäftigte antrag antrag der cdu csu
und jetzt felix landschaftlich für die
grünen ja du und wir haben einen großen
amerikanischen polit fertigungsschritt
zitiert ich möchte ihnen ein zitat eines
großen sozialdemokraten entgegenhalten
politik beginnt mit der betrachtung der
wirklichkeit und was wir heute hier
dargestellt haben auch sie herr bremen
was sie alles nicht passieren würde nur
entlastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger nicht viele unternehmen das hat
schlicht mit der realität nichts zu tun
der parlamentarische trägt er hat es
ausgeführt und viele andere augen wenn
ich mit ihren antrag hier anschaue dann
habe ich mich ein bisschen versetzt
gefühlt in der autofahrt und im
hintergrund läuft hit radio 990 sm das
beste aus den 80ern 90ern und die super
hits von heute das ist nicht das was wir
brauchen
die super hits von heute genau wenn ich
mir ich will nur ich will nur
exemplarisch ein paar dinge darstellen
der kollege rudolf hat auch einiges
angesprochen belastungsmoratorium
sämtliches außerkraftsetzung
lieferketten regulierung all das würde
jetzt gerade nicht gehen der
rohrkrepierer chip als die verheißung
einer großartigen zukunft und dann und
das muss man mir wirklich mal erklären
in der aktuellen situation helfen soll
das was sie schon immer gefordert haben
nämlich die arbeitszeit regulierung
dahingehend verbrechen dass man in
betrieben statt die begrenzte
arbeitszeit am tag das einfach auf die
woche aufzuteilen wie das ein beitrag
dazu sein soll lieferketten
problematiken produktionsengpässe
produktions rückführung energiepreis
problematik hin zu bekämpfen das hat
doch nicht mit der realität nichts zu
tun und deswegen habe ich mich gefreut
über einen satz aus ihrem anschlag
entscheidend dass einerseits die
aktuellen krisen zu überwinden und
andererseits die wirtschaftspolitischen
weichen entschlossen auf
leistungsfähigkeit digitalisierung und
nachhaltigkeit zu stellen ein guter satz
so daraus folgt bei ihnen überhaupt
nichts nada niente wenn sie das ernst
meinen überdenken sie bitte ob das so
eine kluge idee war gegen den
nachtragshaushalt zu klagen der 60
milliarden euro genau für diese
transformation die sie ansprechen zur
verfügung stellen soll das wären beitrag
dazu dieses land in die zukunft zu
führen vielen dank
vielen dank damit schließt sich die
aussprache und wir nähern uns der
entscheidung zunächst tagesordnungspunkt
13 wir kommen zur abstimmung über den
antrag der fraktion der cdu/csu auch
drucksache 1999 mit dem titel
sofortprogramm für unternehmen und
beschäftigte wer stimmt für diesen
antrag
gestimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich dann ist dieser antrag
bei enthaltung der afg fraktionen
gegen die stimmen der cdu csu fraktion
mit den stimmen der fraktionen des
hauses abgelehnt ich rufe auf
zusatzpunkt vier abstimmung über den
antrag der fraktion die linke drucksache
1514 mit dem titel hilfsprogramm für
wirtschaft wohlstand und beschäftigung
wäre stimmt für diesen antrag das ist
die fraktion die linke stimmte dagegen
der rest des hauses damit ist dieser
antrag abgelehnt